hello and welcome to this video j pesos
okay yeah my law my last him live show
ya got me below 2400 again but I it's a
close one after being above that for
quite a while ok go's d 6 against Quincy
to that's a rather flexible move it's
something that I had considered to cover
in my book but ultimately I decided
against it not because the was bad but I
felt that the rising porn structures are
a little bit too on gap what's the right
what's the right word damn you too
inconsistent maybe to do in a book
because black is very flexible which is
a good thing in general but not so easy
to do in a book okay um age 65 how where
are you going to put your king mr. Jay
passes we are not on the kingside maybe
maybe on the King side okay um so he
probably wants to take one two three
hmm I'm not quite sure how to do that I
need I need to probably looked you one
let's go up the one to have a look at d6
put some pressure maybe Bishop d7 now is
a is a good move for black try it now
not sure about it hmm well this is not a
move I had considered at all Knight f3
and what's the idea here yeah here I can
go back to see one was not something bad
I know this is actually ok and
threatening Rupert e6 and 90 x 25 both
are quite an annoyance I don't know how
he covers that I don't think you can
actually g4 maybe maybe g4
yeah that's it so that's still feasible
what to do here 94 it's looking
interesting try to go to be five but he
has Bishop to d7 92 and night b3 is also
an option but he will go to c6 spoon so
94 that's Bishop to d7 I can also go
rook t4 in this position here but it's
not so clear what my next move is then
ok not sure about it but I was in danger
of getting low on time so I wanted to
speed up a little bit
I think you should do something about
the pawn 25 my idea and screen e5 was to
play Queen to d2 but I'm not that's not
even threatening something oh ok taking
doesn't do anything good rook t4 as an
option attacking g4 as well and setting
up I'm Queen d2 ok well h5 I could have
taken something that I only now really
recognize well we should do three it's
not doing that much Quincy to is
probably going back tuck position tough
position between a three maybe it's
something where I would absolutely like
to have more time to understand better
what's going on
maybe bishops is 6m he's probably not in
such bad shape here man okay that's not
a move i was thinking of okay threatens
made so but also he sets up a possible
pin year for himself Bishop d3 I have to
cover up to the first my black is okay
he can go if i push up to six moon and
yep that didn't really convince much my
play I mean okay no 95 I can actually
take okay I thought details I can think
I can do that d take screen be seven is
a move I think not sure look the eight I
have no square for the rook this is a
problem so we might have 95 and then
takes D takes root is 17 d 727 check
that screen c 7 Chen okay you can also
just paper shop c 6 that's nothing wrong
with that movie done that one okay know
that that I'm taking definitely
ok c 5 is not going to work I just
wanted to have the the King misplaced on
I'm not sure how this place it really is
but in the center how to use that night
now I can go to d2l then Bishop c6 and
the other night he is not doing anything
I think this is better right getting it
to deform looks quite unconvincing what
I'm doing here but okay maybe I'm active
enough yet to be somewhat okay knight c6
and then you will take here hmm i don't
want to trade take some time whining
king of one that looks looks wrong I can
take well I can take and play this and
this might be interesting look here is
interesting though look at five I mean I
probably should have got to eat oh okay
go there now I gotta see porn
mmm that feels okay for me should be
were cmn hmm but I whatever what am i
doing actually that's easy to say I'm
Bishop c5 oops I Bishop b5 I mean that's
that's terrible I should have thought
about that hope I didn't see at all
check okay dad gave me that rook a very
lucky game I was very unconvincing plain
black forfeits on time now I didn't
really have a good concept whole game
it's kind of kind of kind of strange Jim
I don't believe in this opening for
lucky I think I should be fine down
because I don't really see why his king
is going to be in the long run but maybe
this is not a big issue yeah maybe King
only seven is ok and it's possible it
looked a bit strange to me probably this
isn't a great idea to allow him to
double my pawns with hindsight but ok
the only way to avoid it is this after
which I thought he can at least do this
kind of thing and well here black is ok
for sure now the King position is no
problem even though it's very debatable
if you really wants to take now you can
play a move
like that for example and it's not
obvious what my next move is ok ok this
one and now we got to this position and
here black is ok this I found surprising
and I thought also not so great but ok I
didn't understand that I can just do
this and you cannot have your d6 over
hmm ok yeah yeah why just win sir I'm
just winning in this position ok yeah I
knew during the game that I'm playing
badly but afterwards sir you see what
kind of simple stuff you have missed
here black is just fine engine wants to
do this and gets black a clear advantage
yes the better pawn structure and I
don't have a clear idea what to do I can
put some pressure on the six but it's
not so great yeah oh yeah i thought i'm
ok again but and here I'm definitely
okay after this but I'm losing so much
time here playing playing strange movie
I look at this this is completely
without any plan yeah night there can
therefore Queen 85 yeah yeah after
taking I think I should be ok but it I
play miss played it again the engine
once through this is probably better
it's the line
hmm ok yeah I'm sure yeah this is
probably not great ultimately I is
playing this completely fun and now yeah
I went here now I better because this
Bishop is bad but funny enough this is
stronger and then I'm taking this next
possibly this thing okay this is looks
good but the sea porn it wasn't good it
wasn't strong and this is also probably
just wrong yeah oops sorry that was
wrong wrong button and yeah yeah it
didn't see anything anything decent okay
he could have taken on c4 I thought I
had this oh but i have just overlooked
this move oh wow that was one of the
worst games ever here i was playing like
you could be more on Jan oops what and
oh I went here and instead I can do this
and just win oh my was a really terrible
game oh I come on let's play a new game
staring at this any longer is probably
hood in my side whoo thanks for me mmm
yeah being tough by watching this game